-My next guest is about
to kick off his fifth season
as Jughead Jones on The CW's
hit show "Riverdale,"
which returns
January 20th at 8:00 p.m.
Here's my man, Cole Sprouse!
Oh! [ Laughs ]
Yeah, you did it.
You did it to me again.
Oh, my God. I love it.
-All the way
back from Peru, man.
-You've outdone yourself, buddy.
I'm so happy to see you.
You know, I have an interesting
fact for you, Cole.
Today is January 15th.
And did you know that your first
solo appearance on this show,
a few years ago,
was also on January 15th?
-Really?
-You even drew a picture of me.
You drew a portrait of me
at the time.
I don't know if you remember.
I saved it.
-And this is it.
-I hope so. Oh, geez.
I must admit, I've gotten
a lot, lot better since then.
And next time I get to see you
and be blessed
with your presence in person,
I have another one
coming for you.
It's my little gift
every time I come on the show.
And by the way,
January 15th is now my day.
-Cole Sprouse Day?
-It's my day. Yes.
-January 15th is Cole Sprouse
Day on "The Tonight Show."
Every year, you will be here?
-Regardless of if I'm in Peru
or I'm locked up in prison,
I'll find a way
to make sure that I call you.
-At least we got a phone call.
That's just --
That's a guarantee, buddy.
-Yeah.
-Please.
-And maybe some bail,
if I'm actually in jail.
Help me out.
-Where are you now, though?
Are you filming "Riverdale" or
you're quarantining?
-I am quarantining,
so I am back up in Vancouver.
We start the second half
of the fifth season on Monday.
So I'm almost out of
the lockdown.
-I wanted to ask you
about something I heard
and I never knew.
It's about you
and your brother.
Is it true that you were
named after Nat King Cole
and your brother
was named after Dylan Thomas?
-You know, I've heard people --
Now, Dylan Thomas
is probably way more legitimate,
because his middle name
is Thomas.
But Nat King Cole --
I've heard Cole Porter.
I think that used
to be something when Dylan and I
were going through our,
like, young-child-star
publicity circuit.
My mom would just say it because
it sounded artsy, you know?
-Yeah, exactly, yeah.
-I'm really just named
after, like, cabbage, coleslaw.
That's the definition
of my name.
It comes from cabbage farmer,
I think, is --
-But Cole and Dylan --
they're great names.
-I think Cole's pretty great.
I think Dylan
could use a little work.
-Dude, you and your brother,
by the way, are --
Your brother's
coming back to TV.
He's in the
new Mindy Kaling show.
And, yeah, it was big news.
And then I don't know
if you remember
what you commented on Twitter,
because I follow both.
Do you remember
what you said?
-Yeah. I asked him
what the crew was going to do
when they find out
he's just not funny.
-You go back and forth.
And I was actually going
to show you some examples,
because this one thing --
You troll each other and, like,
roast each other online.
This one time, you asked
your brother, @dylansprouse,
"Were you Zack or Cody?"
Now, that's funny in itself.
I give props for that.
I give a like on that one.
I give a couple snaps.
But then your brother responded,
and he said,
"I don't remember, actually.
I was too busy
carrying the show on my back."
[ Laughs ]
That got the clap from me there.
That was fantastic.
Did this start on social media
or is this always
just a brother thing?
-No. I mean,
this is how I feel like
healthy brother
relationships end up
speaking to each other.
-Yeah, a healthy ribbing.
-And we keep each other,
accountable,
keep each other humble.
But, yeah, it hasn't gotten
pushed too far yet,
though, which is good.
I'm always, like --
I'm always nervous
that one day, one of us
is going to say something
that really, like, stings
a little bit too deep.
And we'll get
one of those calls like,
"Why would you do that,
dude, to the public?"
-"You took it too far, man.
You took it too far.
It was funny,
but you took it too far."
I want to talk about
"Riverdale."
-Okay.
-This season is about
to jump ahead to the future.
We have a big-time jump.
Yeah.
-I'm excited.
Explain what's happening.
-I'm excited for it, too.
So, we had to shut down,
obviously,
because of the COVID lockdown,
at the final three episodes
of last season.
So the first three episodes
of this new season
are us finishing those ones.
-Wow.
-And in Episode 4,
we do a big-time jump
and we all leave Riverdale
at the end of Episode 3
and come back seven years later.
So I actually do get to play
roughly my age,
which is wonderful.
-Yeah! The first episode
is the prom, and --
-Yeah. The day
we actually shot the prom
was the last day before we got
the official shutdown
and were all sent back
to the States.
-Wow. What a send-off.
-Yeah, It was kind of funny.
Well, you know, we celebrated
like it was a real prom.
We were pouring some drinks.
We were having some fun.
We were singing karaoke.
It was a really wonderful time.
And then we got
the shutdown next day.
And so, in some strange
kind of way,
we had all celebrated
and reveled without knowing that
that was going to be kind of
this life-changing event.
And we finished the
prom and then we all kind of
went on our separate ways for
the entirety of the quarantine.
-So when people watch that,
it has another --
like, another
special meaning to it.
I want to show
everyone a clip, buddy.
Here's Cole Sprouse in
the season premiere of
"Riverdale."
Take a look.
-No, I won't help you.
-No, no.
Cheryl, it's not
an actual snuff film.
It's an act.
It's a way
to get closer to the auteur,
the person who's been creating
those re-enactment videos,
including the one with
Jason and your father.
-I do want to expose
that defiler.
What's this movie about anyway?
-Uh, it's a classic tale,
one as old as time.
A girl meets a boy,
boy promises
to make girl a star,
and -- and the
boy kills the girl.
-[ Chuckles ]
Charming.
Okay, but I'll need a wig.
I don't want anyone to recognize
me by my signature red mane.
-Okay.
-Cole Sprouse,
Season 5 of "Riverdale"
premieres this Wednesday at
8:00 p.m. on The CW.